(crickets chirping)
(passionate moaning)
- Oh.
Ugh.
(passionate moaning)
(soft music)
(knocking)
- [Mom] Time to get up, darling.
- Okay, Mum.
Oh shit, I'm late.
Mum, have you seen my blue shirt?
- [Mum] It's in the laundry room, darling.
- Oh, thank you.
Mum, I can't find my blue shirt.
I miss you so much and
everything's horrible.
- Girls, are you ready to go?
- Yes definitely, I just
wanna get a selfie first.
(soft music)
Yay, that's cute.
- [Group] Yeah, I like that one.
(sighs)
Yeah, I'm just gonna pop to Tesco,
then probably get a coffee at Costa
and then I'll meet you at Tricia's.
(sighs)
Where's room C?
Excuse me, is this room C?
No, okay.
I give up.
- Is he from...?
- Popcorn.
(yells)
(laughs)
- Oi, shut up.
- No, I just wanna know.
- Do you know?
- No I don't know,
that's why I'm watching.
- No one knows.
(soft music)
- Thank you, Mum!
Looks great.
(laughs)
Yes.
(sighs)
(upbeat music)